elle est là fallait grévistes sont plus
que jamais déterminés à poursuivre leur
mouvement
leur mouvement et ce jusqu'au retrait
complet la réforme des retraites
oui absolument sophie se sont retrouvés
tout à l'heure donc à midi ici à bercy
il était un peu plus de 200 personnes
rassemblées ici
et puis le rpt le rassemblement a duré à
peu près deux heures ils viennent de
partir il reste encore quelques
grévistes qui sont sur place d'ailleurs
je suis avec christophe payen qui est
contrôleur des finances et qui est du
syndicat solidaires bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions c'était important pour vous
d'être là ce matin pour ce rassemblement
bien entendu puisque les annonces du
premier ministre concernent que lâche
rivaux qui est un des éléments de cette
réforme
ce qu'il ya de malheureux c'est que il
faudrait que tous les salariés de france
soit dans la rue parce qu'on va tous
prendre plein la tête qu'on soit du
privé ou du public
il suffit simplement c'est mathématique
un calcul des pensions de retraite qui
est sûre calculé sur l'ensemble de la
carrière et non pas sur les meilleurs
mois de salaire forcément c'est
mathématique
le montant de la retraite ou de la
pension pour la fonction publique sera
inférieur à ce qu'il est actuellement
alors le gouvernement qu'un fait des
annonces ce week-end pour essayer de
trouver une issue à cette crise vous
vous n'êtes pas convaincu les annonces
du gouvernement c'est de la
communication
on sait bien que le premier ministre en
train de jouer la division syndicale
avec d'un côté la cfdt avec l'ach pivot
et la retraite par points que toutes les
autres organisations syndicales de
salariés refusent c'est pas nouveau ça a
déjà été fait pour d'autres la loi
travail ça a été un peu la même façon de
faire après vous avez très bien vu que
de toute façon si les partenaires
sociaux n'arrivait pas à trouver des
pistes
le premier ministre a déclaré qu'il
réagit ray par ordonnance autrement dit
le vous pouvez toujours causer
il n'en sortira rien et je déciderai ce
que je veux c'est exactement ce qu'on
pense tous tous ceux qui sont là et qui
sont très nombreux à travers la france
en train de manifester
42e jour de mobilisation votre
détermination reste intacte et bien sûr
on lâchera rien de toute façon il faut
bien se dire que c'est un choix de
société que tous les français je dis
tous les salariés devraient être dans la
rue quel que soit le la propagande
gouvernementale dans les médias il faut
pas lâcher sur un truc comme ça après ça
va être la sécurité sociale moi je suis
content des deux français d'avoir un
pays comme le nôtre et je ne veux pas
ressembler à d'autres pays européens ou
à travers le monde où les gens soient
exploitées tout le long de leur vie et
même jusqu'à la mort une dernière
question de superbes de monde il tout
simplement le retrait pur et simple de
cette réforme
exactement retrait pur et simple de la
réforme des retraites
de monsieur de le voir le démissionnaire
on ne veut pas de cette réforme on
lâchera rien qu'on sera toujours là
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
vous entendez sophie des manifestants
qui reste déterminé qu'ils vont
poursuivre ce bras de fer ce sont leurs
mots avec le gouvernement tant qu'il
n'aura pas tout simplement retirer cette
réforme des retraites
merci beaucoup les la femme ou vous
depuis à bercy cela